[Music]
where is it
i put it over there by the couch yeah
[Music]
an electric eel magnificent
[Music]
our submarine is docked here
in the amazon
river we could have gone to the orinoco
river but our deer desiree wouldn't fit
this is the only other place in the
world
to find electric eels
exactly
electric eels are quite the peculiar
species they're like aquatic batteries
the majority of their body is made up of
organs that produce electricity
listen
you can hear it
also obligate air breathers which means
they must surface every 10 minutes or so
to breathe above water
scientists at vanderbilt university you
know
hold on let's get kenneth on the line
[Music]
bonjour kenneth so i hear your team has
some interesting findings eh
yeah we discovered something really
remarkable so when you threaten or
corner an electric eel it can leap out
of the water and put its chin onto you
so that the current is
sent straight through your body and back
down to the water giving maximal shock
how
shocking
now how do these eels generate all that
electricity well they have modified
muscles that in the course of evolution
are now just used to generate
electricity and they line these up in
series to generate high voltages and
create a very powerful shock
thanks kenneth and
say height of the misses for me okay
these eels might be dangerous but
once they shock their prey they need
time to recharge
so you probably won't get shocked are we
safe
there's no cover on the tank yeah sure
[Music]
you